what up guys I just want to start by
saying I used to make fun of the Jews I
hang out with listen and podcast all the
time I did not understand people
listening and grown men just straight up
talk for an hour but you really do make
the time pass while I'm at work except
I'm case notes so holla for that but I
want to know who we have winning in a
fight Bert Kreischer with his body build
or Ari Shaffir whose lanky arms probably
could scratch the hell out of Bert so
what you got Bert or re first of all you
know it is interesting the type of
people that like to listen to podcast a
lot of time truckers delivery people
killers and other types of people bank
tellers bank tellers yeah you throw that
one piece in you can enjoy it tarot card
yeah magicians
I don't like magician men either out of
breath room they don't listen to this
let's march nemesis I'll tell you this
though young lady what are you asking
Bert Kreischer Ari Shaffir who would win
in a fight I'm have to take art affaire
he's scrappy his his family did go
through the Holocaust so there's that I
feel like Ari has some darkness that
Bert doesn't have or likes have a good
time I wants to kill you yeah Ari dairy
has that never surrender like if I told
Ari to run across the United States I
feel like you'd eventually get there
burnt might die in the process
yeah Berta has that kind of carotid
artery kind of style to him I think you
know that posture like part of his
posture at the an you like is that you
know is that just kind of build up in
his arteries it's really holding him up
and Ari Shaffir does he seem like that
strong yeah he's got family I think
maybe been through the Holocaust I'm not
sure I think so he's got a little bit of
that he looks like a guy who maybe like
dealt cards in the Holocaust you know
was the I feel like Ari has that
castaway vibe you know I'm saying like
he looks like he could do well on the
castaway he looks like he can pretend he
was dead for a long time and then get up
and still kill you like all he's got or
it looks like the dude that will not die
you'd have to really really kill him
yeah I can't have to kill him and like
Daffy and here's where bird he's gonna
talk you how to kill him cuz he's so
friendly
yeah Bert's gonna try to be so friendly
and then he's just gonna eat all a bunch
of snacks and then probably get sick and
passed away but so I would say re in a
heartbeat dude already see him I'm the
kind of guy who has swords he's in
different countries a lot
you know I well traveled different paths
ports drugs spy easily easily easily man
and rere is uh Arya's are not afraid to
kind of he's a little bit more
aggressive than Berta's yeah are you
break your heart yeah yeah or you'll
break yard and then break the [ __ ]
rest to you while you boom are you
shoving no bread yeah Ari Shaffir and
the fans say 53% go Bert Kreischer oh
wow Wow he's the Mickey Mantle we bet
that's because Bert Bert has more an
online presence in our he does so more
people might have voted for already has
a flip phone yeah
far as a foot voting usually is just him
saying he doesn't have a phone and
[ __ ] flipping you all
[Music]